premier arrivé premier servi elle sent
très bon allez parfumée elle est jolie
c'est vrai la couleur à l'ouverture du
marché
pas de place pour les débutants il faut
être efficace concentrer d'abord
l'observer sentir son parfum
la tournée l'a retourné en changer
recommencer recommencer encore et puis à
un moment se décider acheté à ma moi
c'est je cherche une truffe qui est déjà
de l'eau d'heure parce que je trouve
c'est ça qui est important
peu plus plus que le goût l'ouïe enfin
le prix on s'attend toute façon ce sera
ce sera pas donnée mais c'est quoi c'est
normal c'est pas mal ça tout va très
vite les plus belles parts dans quelques
minutes
dès l'ouverture extra c'est 1000 euros
1re catégorie 950 et 2e 850 les
producteurs ont eu très peur de la
sécheresse de l'été ils sont rassurés 33
kg de truffes à vendre aujourd'hui c'est
à peu près autant que l'année dernière
beaucoup ont été obligés d'arroser pour
assurer la récolte
c'est le tout début on ne peut pas dire
c'est vraiment la première école qui
hier et durera jusqu'au 15 février donc
les plus belles en janvier on verra si
on en a d'autres pas voilà en attendant
le prochain marché
les chefs ont commencé à travailler le
produit d'un côté la truffe fraîche sur
saumon cru pour le chef de l'hôtel
matignon
et là on va vous faire un suprême de
volaille truffé on va déclencher ou
porto montée crème fraîche
1 par exemple et je vais vous servir
chan soyons pas chauvins avec une
lentille verte du berry il faut en
trouver des trucs pour transformer un
plat en mai de fait après tout est
question de mesure ni trop ni trop peu
les gourmands apprécié a été bien sage
m